thanks very much jun and thanks very
much for the
invitation to be here it's truly
fantastic and i'm looking forward to a
couple of weeks
and talking to people so i'm going to
talk about work that i've been doing
trying to
look at new ways of thinking about
genetic variation data
but there are really a couple of
warnings about this talk before i start
the first
is that this is somewhat work in
progress so it's not all totally
signed and sealed the second is that at
some level what i'm going to
be talking about is rather boring
because it's it's not really to do with
doing deep inference about underlying
processes
from genetic variation data it's really
all about the data itself and trying to
have good ways of describing the raw
information that we use
as population geneticist in order to
make those
inferences
so just to give you a sense of what i
mean by that
i want to give you a feeling for how at
least my
thinking about genetic variation and
genetic variation data has changed over
the years
a long way back i was young and naive
and i used to think that population
genetic data looked like this
that you would have essentially a binary
incidence matrix that would say
you've got a bunch of chromosomes that
you've sampled from a population each
row
here and then there are a bunch of sites
at which these chromosomes
vary here i've just color-coded them as
blue and yellow
and you can basically treat this as a
matrix of
northern ones so i didn't really think
about how
the data was generated i just assumed
that when it landed on my lap i could
effectively treat it like this now
perhaps one of the great
successes or surprises of population
genetics is really how far you can get
with this
incredibly naive and simplistic view of
what's going on it actually works
remarkably well
but there are places where you actually
have to start thinking
a lot more deeply about the error
structures and the way in which data is
collected
and i think one of these interesting
social
changes that has happened in this area
over the last 10 years or so
is how the study of the the processes
that generate the
the the phenomenon in the in the
population have converged with a
an understanding of the technologies
that actually give us the data in the
first
place so that's how i used to think
about genetic variation data
and then i had an epiphany and i
realized that actually
there's a lot of uncertainty in how we
uh we assemble this information
and in certain areas that uncertainty
can be really important
so for example this is a a pedigree that
where we've been sequencing this is a
pedigree of
chimpanzees and what we were interested
in doing was learning about
the de novo mutation rate now if you
if you take the previous approach and
you
you run the data this was through high
throughput sequencing you run through
the data through standard algorithms
and you get something that looks a bit
like this and then you just go along
counting up the places where the
children look different from the parents
you think the mutation rate is you know
on the order of
ten to the minus five or something per
base per per generation of course it's
not
that's just because the there are a lot
of little errors that are made
in how you uh convert the raw data into
an estimate of the genotype and when
you're looking
for very very rare things like de novo
mutations
ignoring that uncertainty is very
important and so what what you can do in
this case
is say the the data that we collect the
sequence data that we collect
is um an imperfect representation of the
underlying sequence
but with an error structure that is
totally measurable so we can actually
put probabilities of seeing the data
as a function of possible underlying
genotypes and by doing that you can then
devise
pretty sensible statistical methods for
saying
what's the probability of seeing the
data that i've collected over
they're given different models for
example where there's just some
genotyping error
it was a de novo mutation it could have
been a gene conversion or it's a
segregating
deletion and by using these approaches
you can actually get
very good filters if you like that just
allow you to
zoom in on the denominator mutations so
that's
if you like taking how we think about
genetic variation data to
one slightly increased level of
sophistication
but then i had another epiphany and
over the last few years actually what
i've been particularly interested in
is thinking about the data that we
collect in particular high throughput
sequencing data
from essentially the lowest possible
level that is the
the reads that come out of the machine
and how you can put those reeds together
using graph structures that
try and capture as much of the
information you've seen and then you you
want
you can walk through these structures in
particular ways
to try and learn about genetic variation
in different ways
and so really what i'm going to talk
about today is
how we how we might think a bit harder
about these
structures that can be used to
assemble the primary output of
sequencing technologies
and use that for inference about
not just the diversity that we see in
populations but of course the processes
that we ultimately care about
i should say that if people want to
interrupt and ask questions during this
talk i'm more than
more than happy to have that so
what does this talk about what am i
going to try and convince you
the first thing i'm going to do is to
try and convince you that there are
types of variation out there that we
probably care about that are not well
represented by these sort of binary
incidents
or the genotype likelihood models and so
if you believe this variation is
interesting i shall try and motivate it
with some
uh case studies then we need
methods statistical and computational
methods that are good
at accessing this variation and
analyzing it appropriately
and of course given the title you won't
be surprised to hear
that i think there are fairly sensible
graph based ways of doing this
and i'm going to really talk about two
particular applications
one is trying to build a reference graph
for human genetic variation in
particular within the
uh the hla region and and the other is
uh to do with the assembly of
hypervariable
and immune related genes in plasmodium
falciparum
so that's what i want to try and do so
let's give you some motivating examples
why why am i actually bothering going
down
back down to this level in terms of the
royal sequence
so here's an example uh this is the var
variation or variable genes of
plasmodium falciparum
this beast is the primary agent of
malaria
and it's the primary cause of malaria
associated mortality
um i won't go through the life cycle but
the the key thing is that
um the parasite spends a lot of its life
sitting around in red blood cells
now the thing about red blood cells is
they don't have a nucleus which is great
if you're a parasite
which means there's there's no sort of
immune system that
that is going to get you but they're
also bad because red blood cells
are actually uh turned over pretty
rapidly by the spleen so you're not
going to last long if you're just
sitting in a red blood cell
so what the parasite does is it covers
the surface of the red blood cell with a
large number of sticky
uh proteins these are called pf
emp ones plasmodium falciparum
erythrocyte
membrane protein number one and what
these things do
is they stick to receptors
on epithelial cells so the red blood
cells get stuck to the size of
capillaries
and things like that and that stops them
being flushed away to the spleen and
being got rid of
so that's a great design from the
parasites point of view but of course
by sticking things on the surface of
these red blood cells
it makes itself immediately visible to
the immune system
in particular the antibody part of the
immune system
so you've got these things floating
around and of course
we're very good at mounting antibody
responses
and that would allow us to get rid of
the parasite very quickly
so what the parasite does to get around
that is to actually have a very
broad repertoire of these genes
and not just broad but incredibly
diverse so every parasite you look at
has about 40 to 60 or so of these
proteins it only chooses one to
to put on the surface of a red blood
cell at any any point it switches which
one it uses
and there's huge diversity in these
proteins so let me
show you what i mean by that here's just
this is an attempt
and believe me this is just an attempt
to do multiple sequence alignment
you can see there are some bits of it
which are relatively conserved
but there's huge amounts which are
hugely hugely diverse
so these are these sort of sit around
the genome of of the falciparum
but they're not they're not well-behaved
genes it's not like there's
a gene here and you go to the next
parasite and you'll find an ortholog
that looks somewhat like it
actually they have this system which
shuffles this variation hugely so
these genes sort of move location they
can hop from one telomere to another
telomere
they can undergo processes of
recombination so they have lots of
internal mechanisms for generating
variation
so if you want to look at this variation
and try and understand the processes
that have
led to it you're faced with this issue
of how do you actually look at data that
looks
something like this well the first thing
you might do is to
say well i've got a multiple sequence
alignment let's try making a tree
and when you make a tree of these
sequences you find that
there's not really much structure there
there are a few that are kind of related
to each other
these little clusters up here but apart
from some
kind of interesting optical illusions
down here there's essentially
no structure in this state of whatsoever
so it's
sort of kind of mindless so
how do you go from that how do you
actually start
look looking through these data for for
patterns
well one thing you can do is you can say
well let's not try and look at the whole
sequence
at once but let's sort of break this
down into little words
let's take imagine taking windows of
nine amino acids sliding them along um
and whenever two sequences share a
particular
nine letter amino acid word you can sort
of merge them into one
and in regions where they they're
variable then you'll see
some going one way some going another
way
that's a very informal description of
what this is but as you can see this is
just a
essentially a graph representing the
variation that was in that multiple
sequence alignment
and this very clearly shows these
regions of strong conservation and then
this
these regions where there's a huge
amount of diversity
but what you see when you try and sort
of push into this in more detail
is that there is some structure within
here there are some sequences that sort
of cluster together locally
but if you find the sequences that
cluster together locally up here they're
unlikely to be clustered together
locally down there rather there's
a process of recombination essentially
that is shuffling the variation up among
these genes
and although i'm not going to go into
the detail of how we did this
and if you take what you can do is to
say
here's one of these protein sequences i
want to
reconstruct that sequence as an
imperfect mosaic of other sequences
in this data set that allows you to find
sort of relationships between sequences
and others within this set and what you
what you find this is just a
viterbi decoding of the process is you
get this sort of mosaic structure so
this is a
this is a sequence from one of the
chimpanzee parasites
and you can see that there's a a
block-like
mosaic process that relates this to that
and here's another one again a
chimpanzee sequence
where there's large stretches of
homology to sequences that you find in
humans
and that wouldn't be that wouldn't at
all be visible from
a straightforward alignment so here's a
situation where
sort of standard alignment doesn't work
but when you
when you devise ways of looking at the
data
interesting fashions you can see
evidence that there's a
these little bits of sequence are being
maintained over long
evolutionary periods but are being
shuffled up all the time
so that's one example here's another
this is if you like
is the human counterpart of the the var
story
this is one of our most
variable regions of the genome this is
the class 1 hla region
the class 1 h lay genes are what present
bits of protein that are in cells
to our immune system so all of our cells
have these mhc proteins on them
and what they do is they take proteins
all the proteins that you find in
in your cells they break them up into
little bits those are loaded onto these
receptors if you like and then shown to
the outside world and in particular
shown to the immune system
if this protein is something that is
normally in you
that's fine your immune system won't
respond but if this happens to be a bit
of viral
protein that's kicking around your cell
that will elicit a response from your
immune system that will come and kill
the cell
and and you'll get um clearance of the
virus in that case
so these are sort of the key features of
our
um one of the key features of our
adaptive immune system
so the very so these genes the class one
genes there are
three of them a b and c they're encoded
within the hla region
on chromosome six each one of these loci
is very diverse
so for example at the b locus there are
well over 2 000 different sequences
described
at the protein level so for over
2 000 haplotypes if you like
of protein sequence within the class
1 mhc at hlab and this is just
a plot of showing the frequency of
certain key alleles
around the world and any population
geneticist would know
that these are very highly
differentiated and
and probably reflect something to do
with the different exposure to different
pathogens that populations have had
over evolutionary time so very diverse
but that that notion of very diverse
is actually is a very simple statement
it doesn't doesn't tell us
much about what's going on within the
system
how is it structured are there
relationships between what you see in
these
different loci
and again one thing that we can do is
just to
make simple structures
graphical structures that represent
something about the variation that you
see in these
loci which allow us to find some kind of
interesting patterns
they're just descriptions of the data
essentially but they're
it trying to describe the data in ways
that allow you to pick up interesting
biological processes so for example
if you take the hla a loci you can make
a
graph that summarize something about the
variability as you move along the
sequence so again we've just taken
the protein sequences and we're moving
along in a window here of
actually this is the dna sequence of
like 31 bases and we
say whenever there are two alleles that
share the same 31 letters
and then you're going to collapse those
into two
those two into one and you can you can
make a graph structure that can be
visualized like this
it's very simple it doesn't really show
very much
so that's actually a you take h lay b
now h lab is related to hla a
it's um they kind of do the same thing a
b
and c we don't really know why you've
got three different
loci for this at all so you can do this
for b
you can also do it for c which again
kind of does the same thing as a and b
it is again expressed on all our cells
see there's a bit more structure within
c which is kind of interesting but then
the
the very interesting thing comes when
you put them all together
and what you find is a complete mess but
if you look carefully into this complete
mess you find plenty of cases
where actually there's a lot of shared
sequence between
these three loci so this the c is the
um sorry a is the green one but you can
see b and c
actually there are lots of cases where
these are essentially tracking the same
and so what this tells you and again i'm
not going to go into any more detail on
this
is there's actually a lot of traffic
between the different loci that's
essentially caused by gene conversion
so rather than thinking this about one
gene over here one gene over here and
one gene over here
you really need to think about the three
as a as a family where there's actually
a lot of
uh crosstalk between the different
members of it
through recombination like processes so
i think that's an interesting
observation
and you know we'd like to understand
what was going what's going on here by
uh taking this on to look at what's
going on in great eights for example
yeah one bit of confusion make it a lot
clearer
do these graphs require construction of
a multi-sequence alignment first
is it just a graphical representation of
them so
they require limited statement about
homology and but they don't require a
multiple sequence alignment
so you have to so what they what they
essentially require you to
to say is if you find this k-mer
here in this sequence and you find this
k-mer in the same
in a different sequence those are
homologous
okay so they require statements about
essentially illegalism rather than
homology does that make sense so um
it requires some sense that these are
alignable but it doesn't actually
require a multiple sequence alignment
okay
uh absolutely no good reason whatsoever
and there's no biological absolutely no
biological reason and i'll later i'll
talk about
how we we relax that actually that's
that's just
it's one of the unpleasant things in
making grass but
so you want to get rid of that and we
can actually get rid of that choice
later
and also the vertical heights that's
just some algorithm that that's just
arbitrary minimizers crossing over
exactly
it's exactly that one yeah
just as as explaining it's it's just to
it's a way of representing it so as you
minimize
the crossing lines so it's just a
standard
you know it's one of these off the shelf
packages for showing uh for illustrating
networks
there are other ways that you might
choose to show this and i'll give you
i'll get i'll give you an example of
that later
yeah sorry and then again
yeah so that's an important point this
and it's kind of on this point that you
it's to do
if you see the same camera multiple
times you don't want to try aligning
uh those to each other so this does
require this essentially
noise um duplicate cameras
okay so you kind of mask those out when
you make this
and then you can you can sort of say
that this
is version a and version b of the same
okay
so if the length of the genes doesn't
match
how do you align it i mean do you
stretch from the beginning to the end
and then the scale is different for a g
um if they don't match then i don't have
a particular problem with that as long
as there are bits of them that are
essentially homologous
so i'm talking about the representation
so you go from one of the genes to the
other end of the gene
yeah right yeah i don't know are the
lengths of the genes
pretty much yes there is some variation
but that's not really very important
actually because it
what you require is that if you find
this camera here
in sequence a and the same camera and
sequence b that those are essentially
you can line those up you can then have
different parts of different lengths
as long as they will line up again when
they next
share a camera okay so you can have
bigger loops on one side than another
side
that's perfectly legitimate but in terms
of just a representation
sure we've we've then stretched it so
that everything appears the same length
and they all have to be in the same
order right you can have inversions
or yes so yes well spotted so in
versions of
the killer for this um and i made sure
there are known versions here
you know can i just ask just for
clarification
you you he pointed to these things and
saying homology but then you mentioned
that the
functional biology of these things is
similar
but not well understood often yeah and
so i'm wondering to what extent one has
to be open to the idea that
these things are convergent you know
the same viruses and presenting them
right that's right and they are
independent mechanisms
for doing that they're essentially
equivalent they essentially use the same
machinery
yes so yeah i guess what i'm saying is i
i don't really understand why
if you i see a particular part of a of a
c
allele and a b allele that looked
similar
i think why those couldn't be there by
convergent
evolution i'm not saying they
couldn't be there by convergence so some
this could be convergence right
absolutely fine but you definitely see
uh you know if i went up to k of 100
you'd still see lots of sharing
okay so by that time you're probably
less
the the hypothesis of convergence is
less i wasn't thinking of the really
long stretches yeah i'm just thinking if
you're pointing to these now clearly
clearly if you go you know take the
extreme and you go down to a single
amino acid
then convergence is quite likely yes at
that level so there's a there's a sort
of a spectrum of credibility from
the singular massive amino acid to the
100
amino acids some of the functional
domains
in the actual hlr mod are quite small
yes absolutely um but they're
20 30 amino acids long
when you see homology over identity over
that stretches
i think the hypothesis of convergence
yes well this is this is actually a dna
sequence you're not distinguishing
no not in this one
okay so that's example two example three
hurry up here uh so
uh those are cases where we've taken
quite diverse and quite difficult
loci and we've so we know that that's
that's going to be somewhat complicated
here's a different example which
is actually much closer to a lot of
what's going on in
whole genome sequencing at the moment
which is trying to assemble
variation across again the hla region
here not the the class 1 region but the
class 2
region so the class 1 alleles are what
are presented by all your cells
they're they're going around and that's
what used from
presenting uh from everything there's a
separate set of low cycle the class two
alleles
which are used by what are called the
professional antigen presenting cells
so these are the serious bits of your
immune system
and these are again extremely variable
and they're variable not just in in the
sequence content of the individual loci
there's also a lot of variation in
in gene number so there are these drb1
for examples from these class to loci
but
they're also drb four five six threes
which are and they're variable in copy
number so some people might have a three
some
some people might not um so there's a
lot
sort of paralogy there and there's a lot
of
broader structural variation within this
region
and so when you take an individual and
you you try and map
reads back to the this class ii region
using a standard single reference which
is called pgf
that's what the one that's in grc37 for
example
and you look at coverage you get this
incredibly sort of messy coverage
and then a lot of the reeds around this
region show strange features like
the pairs map to the wrong chromosome or
the pairs are way too far
apart or they're in the wrong
orientation and when you zoom into the
alignment you see a complete mess
like that which you would certainly
wouldn't want to try and um work with
so from the perspective of trying to
assemble variation within this region
then actually uh the single reference
doesn't work very well and it's
very hard to access the variation within
this
region using our standard approaches
but in this particular case actually
this is just from one
individual we can cheat because we
actually know
which haplotypes and this individual
carries because they weren't actually
one of the individuals
used uh for the the construction of the
references
and what many of you may not be aware of
is although we think of the human
references
as just sort of a three billion base
pair string
actually there are some bits of it like
the hla where people have gone to the
trouble of assembling different versions
of that sequence
and so we know actually that this
individual carries one that's called pgf
and another that's called man and if you
just
do the naive thing of taking um the
reference genome standard reference
genome
and augmenting it with another cottage
which is essentially the manhattan type
and remapping the reeds to this slightly
augmented
genome then what you see is that the
coverage looks much neater
and you you massively reduce these
nasty reads you still get some spikes
that are telling you that things
are going wrong but but it looks much
nicer
and you can quantify that in various
ways for example this is the fraction
this is the total number of
uh reads that map here to the single
case you get a load that are
badly mapped and then bunch that are
decent and then when you do
when you map to this augmented reference
you get
many more than that well and many fewer
than that badly
so what this tells you is in this region
and this is going to be the general
statement that i'm going to use to
motivate the rest of this talk that
we actually know a moderate amount about
variation in this region and variation
more generally
across the genome but when we're trying
to characterize variation within these
regions
we don't use it very well if we could
use it
that's if we could map to all these
different versions simultaneously
we might end up with a much better
understanding
of the primary data that goes into our
downstream
um inference
so that's a that's essentially the
preamble to this talk
speed up um so
so where am i going with this
what i've said is that there's a lot of
diversity
that's quite difficult to get at but
given that we know quite a lot of
about genetic variation already we
should use that information to try and
help us
assemble the genome in the next
individual
so it's essentially i think this is a
population genetics insight
one of the more powerful insights that
that's widely used in
sort of statistical inference um is that
novel sequences tend to look like those
we've already seen
um although you need to allow for a
mutation and recombination and
quite often you actually need rather few
references or reference sequences to
capture the vast majority of sequence
space
most things that you look at look like
some kind of mosaic of a relatively
limited number
of reference sequences
and so we'd like to use that insight so
the big question then is how you
formalize that relationship and how you
make that work in the context of
assembling
the next genome and of course
interpreting it
so yeah david to what extent are these
problems a short read phenomenon that
gets overcome with longer reasons what
extent are they
going to be still there with longer
readers
and i think there are two answers to
that one is
in the short term long reads
can help but the current generation of
long reads is quite
error pro which makes using them out of
the box quite hard so i think in the
short
term actually you'll want a mixture of
short high quality reads and the longer
more error prone reads
and and you'll still need to do things
like this
so that's the sort of short term i think
in the longer term
suppose you could give me you know
everyone in this room's genome assembled
absolutely perfectly
uh haplotypes end to end you'd still
need a way of describing that variation
and that would allow you to analyze it
later and i think
that some of these structures that i'll
talk about are actually quite useful in
that context
so for example the hla stuff i i showed
or the bar stuff
i'm assuming those are perfectly
assembled this isn't about looking at
the primary data
yeah these are thousands or tens of
thousand bases long but in order to see
the structure there you still need to
come up with ways
of looking at substructure so i think
these are ways essentially looking at
substructure within
data which have an application in
but actually are more fundamental
okay so how do we how do we represent
variation how might we try and formalize
the relationship between multiple
references and what you see in
the m plus one c so there are various
structures graph structures that you can
use to represent sequence
and variation one that we're all very
familiar with is notion of a multiple
sequence alignment
where every column in this essentially
has the notion of of homology
it's a strong statement though very
strong statement about homology
and typically you know in something like
that it's clearly not
not true we can't make very strong
statements at least about
our homology on the basis of that
on the other side you we have various
structures that make no statement about
homology
for example de bruyne graph which is
just taking
raw sequence breaking it up into words
of i think 31
or whatever you want and then looking at
how those words overlap with each other
you can make structures called de bruyne
graphs out of that
they're simply a representation of the
raw sequence and there's
no statement of homology made from that
you can try and
make statements about homology by say
thinking about how you map
the adjacencies of bubbles onto say a
reference or something like that
but actually that's not present in the
initial structure
but there are problems with the de
bruyne graph which is that you can't
it's you're fixed at this k and that's
uh it's a
rather unpleasant thing so what you can
then do is sort of
uh you can think about how would you
generalize the de bruyne graph
and here you you come up with things um
which are either called or related to
things called string graphs
which are you can think of the string
graph essentially as a variable
k de bruyne graph and in fact the way we
do it is that we
use a de bruyne graph and augment it
with various
information about paths through the
de-drawing graph
again there's no statement about
homology but you're capturing more of
the information
about the underlying sequences that have
gone
into your uh input
and then the sort of final thing is
again the string graph has no statement
of homology so if you wanted to
go back to making statements of homology
you need to sort of align these
and so here's a structure that you might
call them the line string graph
where you you're going to make
statements as we were discussing earlier
that where two sequences
touch in this where they share
essentially a k-mer
that is essentially unique within the
genome i
you only ever find it once within the
genome where you find those two came as
you're going to be able
to allow yourself to clamp two genomes
together
so that they and then parts that come
out of that represent
alternative uh
alternative paths through uh genome
space
so i'm going to just spend a couple of
minutes trying to tell you a bit more
about that
and here the very um
what we've tried to do to illustrate
this and actually
it's more than proof of principle it's
demonstrate how you can use these
structures
to get a better understanding of what's
going on in the genome
is that we're trying to make a graph
like this for the hla
and that's not just these classical h l
alleles that's the entire three to four
megabase
what's called the extended hla region
and the reason that
we've done that is that it's a region
where we actually know a lot about
variation
it's not well um
it's not well serviced by the standard
approach of mapping short reads to a
reference
so how can we combine all this
information into one
so here's a sort of a cartoon of
what we've got we've got about eight
haplotypes that have been sequenced
using
sanger technologies that sit in glc 37
or 38
these are assembled to different levels
of quality
they've got some quite big structural
changes between them
um but they've all got they've also got
long stretches of
um strong identity
within this there are these
hypervariable classical hl
hla alleles where we obviously know
what's going on these four references
but then we typically have hundreds or
tens or thousands
of other sequences that we might want to
use as alternative paths through the
space of genomes
and then in addition we've got
information from the thousand genomes
about a whole bunch of other snips that
there are across
this region and so we want a structure
that allows us to put
all this information together into a
single graph
um this is kind of what it does you take
all of these
and as i said where you find these
k-mers which are essentially unique
within the genome
you allow yourself to squash them or to
merge two genomes and that gives you a
graphical structure which um
allows you to describe essentially
everything that we've got
over there so this the key thing then is
there's a notion of alignment
there's a notion of illegalism in that
these are the alternative paths
the alternative parts don't actually
have to be homologous this could be
sequenced from mars this could be
sequence from jupiter and
so you don't actually have to make
statements about homology of the
alternative parts but you do make
statements about homology
with the intervening
so we call this a population reference
graph it's a compression of the input
data
we can retain the long the initial
information if we want
most importantly it's a generative model
so we could use this structure to
simulate
new genomes by sort of choosing parts
through this
population reference graph and because
of that structure there's a suggestion
it sort of suggests
an efficient way of doing a genome
inference
that is you take you take um
data from another individual and then
you try and work out which bits of this
graph essentially light up and can you
reconstruct the pair of
paths through this graph that you that
are going to make up an individual
so our current implementation has three
stages
in the stage one you take well the stage
naught
if you like is to construct this
population reference graph
in in terms of the analysis of the next
genome the first thing we do is we take
our
our reads and we convert them to a clean
de bruyne graph
we then take this de bruyne graph and
compare it
to our population reference graph
and we want to try and work out the best
pair of parts through this graph
that are present that are present in
this uh individual
and we do that essentially by using
diagnostic k-mers so we say
within this path there are various
k-mers which are
unique to that bit of the graph i you
don't find them elsewhere
either within this subgraph or across
the rest of the genome that's going to
allow us to find
bits of this that are present in the
individual
we have a an error model that says you
know if you see one of these
don't always go that way so that allows
you to use
the utility algorithm to find the best
pair of paths
through this so what comes out of this
is something we call the chromatite
which looks a bit like
um a string with some bubbles in it
and then we have a final stage which
isn't ideal at the moment
uh which is where we then because this
only
is ever only going to find variation
present in
the reference set we have then have
another stage that where we re
map the initial reads back to this
chroma type to allow us to find novel
variation
this bit's a bit clunky at the moment
and and doesn't seem to do much
all right good are you supposed to do
did you start the diploid here or uh
is that why there's two or three yes
that's right so okay this is human so we
were being deployed so we mapped the
reads back to both
say path one through here and past two
through
through here so gil at that moment
that's when you
recapture the snips that you might have
lost
that's right yeah yeah and it's
i just want to make sure to be honest
i'm this isn't how we're going to do it
in the long term
it's just how we're doing it at the
moment
having it you can do it as a two-stage
thing and that's what we go to next
i'm conscious of time so i'm just going
to very quickly go over the evaluation
so
we're going to compare this to if you
like the best case
mapping based approach which is curtin
stampy
platypus so that's going to be our best
practice mapping based
approach and we've evaluated this on a
bunch of
data snip array data sequence based
typing that sanger typing of the
classical hla alleles
we've because these are based on
bits of the genome that are relatively
easy to find
uh that's somewhat biased so another
thing we've looked at is simply
camera recovery so the k-mers that we
think should be in this individual how
many of them actually do we find in the
sequencing data
and then for one of our individuals
we've got some very long reads
data called molecular data from illumina
which is absolutely gorgeous
but costs a lot unfortunately um
which allows us to sort of look at
longer range
accuracy of the method and as i said a
bunch of samples that
that we've looked at i'm just going to
rattle through what we find
so first of all in terms of snip data
basically
whether you're mapping or using these
graph approaches you basically come up
with the same
inferences and they're all kind of much
of a muchness and very good
so snip array data is easy at the
classical h
lay alleles um in the class one abc
the methods are pretty much the same
actually platypus does extremely well
here
patton should be pleased in the class 2
which are harder
for a mapping based approach you see the
mapping based approach does a lot worse
than the whole
and the reference graph approach does
pretty well it's not perfect
and we haven't yet understood why it's
not perfect possible that
the sequence based timing isn't quite a
hundred percent accurate
is my guess um
so here the the reference graph approach
works quite well
if you look at the camera recovery so
this is how many
so you can for each of these different
approaches you can just
there's a reference a platypus approach
and then
um the straightforward viterbi decoding
and then the
uh augment the amended reference graph
approach
you can ask how many of the cameras that
you think should be in the
prototype do you actually recover and
you can kind of see they all do
remarkably well across this region
the reference does very poorly um
if you ask how many are actually
recovered
then the reference graph approach does
recover more
and does not recover fewer
than the mapping based approach that's
reassuring so
we're doing a little better
there are regions where there's a lot
bigger divergence between methods so
again this is the class two region
and if you look at the red line that's
the platypus
approach you find some regions where a
lot of the cameras you think
should be there you don't actually
recover if you take the graph based
approach
you do much better that's the pink if
you like although there are still some
regions where we
do very poorly so i'm just going to zoom
in on that region
and show you what's going on there
um and to zoom in we've used these
molecular long read technologies
where we um what we have to do is to
align these
long reads to actually the chroma type
and so we've had to do a bit of
uh jiggery pokery to to make that work
um
when you align these to the chroma types
essentially what you find is that the
mapping based approach
is very good at finding is very good
in terms of describing variation
which is not a big
edit distance from the reference that's
what you expect but the
graph methods are much better at finding
the bigger deviations from the reference
so they're not quite as sensitive as the
mapping based approach
but they're much more effective at
finding the bigger
divergences as you'd expect if we just
go back to this region
where there's a big divergence between
them then what we think is actually
happening
is that within
our set of reference haplotypes
we simply haven't covered the space of
variation that you find in the class ii
region
so actually we dug out a here's a contig
from the molecular data that we've dug
out from this region
and what you find within here is that
there's a massive great inversion
compared to any of the
sequences that we have in our reference
and so essentially this is saying that
within
this class ii region our reference set
of haplotypes
is still fundamentally limited and we
need to do more work to try and assemble
a better
a more comprehensive description of
what's going on there
so then finally what i hope i've
convinced you of so far is that
this is a this is a pretty simple-minded
approach we're simply saying
here's a bunch of sequence that we know
about let's take
let's try and put that all together in a
graph so that when we
take sequencing data from the next
sample we can try and reconstruct that
um individual's genome as a series of
paths through this graph
um the it's a good in the sense that we
have a prototype it works
pretty well we can use it to assemble
variation within the hk quite
effectively
our current implementation is not
optimal in a few regards the first is
that it uses
a design graph structure which throws
ray this this longer read
um data so by fixing it k31 and there's
no good reason for doing that
apart from it works uh
then you throw away any information
that's at scales 32 and above
and our two-step chroma type to
remapping of the reads is inefficient
and doesn't seem to add very much so
that's not ideal
and we think that both of these things
can be solved by new data structure
which we're calling an annotated brain
graph which is really
a poor man's approximation to a string
graph but is
much much more efficient than a string
graph where you essentially have a
design graph but then you thread through
it
mini paths which are the information
that you see in the reads
about how k-mers relate to each other so
the here are the blocks of the k-mers
and in this structure you wouldn't a
simple de bruyne graph you wouldn't be
able to navigate from
a to c but if you record this red path
information that allows you to recover
the information
it's a nice structure in many ways you
can use paired information end
information
you can do error correction of reads
very effectively with it
it's essentially it becomes a k agnostic
to brine graph
so if you look at as a function of
camera size how well do you do it
recovering context within
this is a staph aureus genome basically
above cave about 20 you don't
you don't seem to gain very much more by
increasing your k
so essentially in this new structure we
we effectively are making a k agnostic
um de bruyne graph or string graph
it's memory efficient so it's about 50
gig for the first human
you add another human that requires
about another one gig
we think that um as you add in
additional ones that should go roughly
as log of the sample size
so this means we should be able to put
hundreds or thousands of humans in
at once which is quite exciting and it's
it's got a very nice structure and it's
very easy to operate you just have a
drop-in model
based on finding k-mers just with a hash
table
so it's extremely um neat to to operate
and it works well so this is data now
going back to malaria where we're trying
to reconstruct
these var sequences um
so here are a bunch of samples that
we've done from from across
between two reference genomes 3d7 and
hp3 there's a whole bunch of progeny
if you look at the n50 which is a
measure of how long your contigs are
without this new structure you get
tiddly ridley uh context which aren't
good for anything
uh but then with this new structure
you're getting much longer ones it's
still not perfect
but they're a lot longer and some of the
fun things when
then finding is if you start looking
among these progeny you
you start being able to find mosaic
structures which
are indicative of non-allelic homologous
recombination between these var genes
just that process that i started by
describing but that was at a population
level this is actually
the level of a particular cross and
moreover you don't just find
mosaic structures you find complex
mosaic structures
whereby um what you find in a progeny is
a sort of a complex
shuttling backwards and forwards of the
two parental sequences which is much
more like
sort of the template switching process
you see in hiv than
say classic crossing over event
right so i've reached the end uh
hopefully i've convinced you that
uh graph structures for representing
sequence
variation can be quite informative they
can you can use them to see interesting
patterns that you wouldn't have seen
before
and they can also be quite effective in
allowing you to assemble the genome of
your next individual that's quite
quite useful i think it's a way of
saying here's all the knowledge that
we've got before let's use that to try
and assemble what's
what we find in the next individual and
there's a whole bunch of people to thank
in particular
alex diltea who did most of the graph
work isaac who's invented the new data
structure
and zam who's a long-term collaborator
on the whole thing
thank you